The world needs the avatar
It needs you Aang
if our nation is destroyed, everything in their paths,
right.
They're going to say, We're the world.
The world needs you
to remember what it is we're really fighting for.
The ones we
love.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Netflix just released another new avatar,
The Last Airbender trailer for the live action series.
This time with more footage of a couple more characters
from the original series.
I know there's tons of cabbage man questions.
Don't worry, I'll talk about him too.
end, they revealed more details
about how they changed the original storyline
from Book one to fit the new episodes.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I will do episode videos.
Just like I did for the original series
and for Legend of Korra back in the day.
it feels so weird doing Avatar videos again.
Speaking of which, the other really cool news
they haven't talked about it recently,
but Mike and Bryan are making an animated avatar,
The Last Airbender movie
with the adult version of the gaang or team aang
however you want to think about them.
Set after the events of Book three,
which is basically them
doing a version of the comics Now we're making a movie.
Our first movie and so that always as an artist,
that that was like really alluring to me.
can't really wrap my head around the final mix
and the final color correction on the feature.
we're talking about doing multiple projects
at the same time, including feature films.
that really isn't supposed to come until 2025.
It could have been delayed till 2026
because of the strikes last year.
but they're also working on a new animated Avatar
series with the Earth ender
Avatar after Korra set forward in the timeline
that's supposed to release either
right before or right after the brand new movie.
I think it'll come right after they're couple
other animated Avatar movies that they announced.
I'll talk about them at the end of the video
because they're a little bit further off.
but it is a really good time to be an Avatar fan.
Like Avatar fans are going to be eating good
for like the next 30 years.
They'll be Avatar.
Two were all old and gray, probably
the biggest new thing in this new trailer is Aang.
Talking to Monk Gyatso.
This has to be a flashback
before he went into the ice 100 years ago.
Their conversation basically plays out
similar to their conversation in the flashbacks
in the original show, The difference is the way
they actually frame the scenes.
And this is one of the big differences
with the new live action Netflix series,
like some of the changes they made.
They're actually showing
the genocide of the Air Nomads.
So this scene with Aang in Monkey
also is just watching it happening like it's probably
right before he tries to bail on this other air
temple and gets lost in the ice.
right before fire
Lord Susan shows up with the fire nation and attacks
in the original show it's presented as brief flashbacks
with Aang remembering his conversations
with Monk Gyatso in the circumstances that led to him
being trapped in the ice for a hundred years.
So this time we're actually seeing it go down.
This footage from a couple other characters.
Baxter As they do with the same thing with, like, Zuko
getting his scar.
It's not just a flashback this time of someone
remembering it.
We're actually seeing it go down.
would you seen the Aang scene is pretty accurate Aang
found out he was the next avatar at a very young age.
He couldn't handle the pressure.
At first Monk Gyatso became more of a surrogate father
to him at the Southern Air temple,
so he tried to hide a lot of the really difficult stuff
from him until the very last minute.
because he was the avatar.
He was born an airbending prodigy.
He got his Airbender tattoos before he learned
he was the avatar, though.
Like he just grew up thinking that he was a prodigy.
He's meant to be the youngest airbender
in the history of the Air Nomads
to get his tattoos,
Genera was like the next youngest person.
Much, much later in the timeline.
Typically it took a lot longer for air nomads to earn
their tattoos because you have to become a master.
So Aang spent his early life up to about age 12,
traveling to the other air temples
around the world, learning airbending techniques,
getting appa his sky bison.
Then around the time he was turning
12, Susan's comet had already come in.
The fire nation had already started
waging war simultaneously on all the other nations
that had been going on for a while.
and because Monk Gyatso
had been a close friend of Avatar, Roku
and so had Susan Gyatso knew
that Susan would eventually come for the air.
Nomads hoping to eradicate the next avatar
before he could master
all four elements challenging him,
knowing that this would become a really big problem.
Like eventually Susan would come for Aang thus begins
the genocide of the air nomads.
So Monk Gyatso, knowing that this would happen, decides
to tell Aang that he was the avatar around the time
he turned 12 Originally, they would have waited
much longer until he came of age.
But because he was only 12,
like he's still a little kid.
The burden of knowledge of the pending war
with the fire nation, what the rest of the world
expected of him as the avatar,
which is way too much for him to handle.
so like a typical little kid
he took up immediately ran away
after hearing the news of becoming the avatar
and was caught in the storm at sea.
His body basically went to the Avatar state
to protect himself forming the ice shield around him.
And his body just stayed in the Avatar state
for the entire 100 year period that he was in the ice.
some people forget that
he was in the Avatar state for 100 years,
that's actually the reason why he died so young.
He was only 66 when he died.
Normally, avatars can live much, much longer
than normal humans like Avatar Kyoshi,
probably one of the longest live ones lived to see
was about 200 years old.
being in the avatar state for so long taxed ng's body
so much that it just gave out early.
We get more footage inside the Southern Air temple,
too, before the Fire Nation attacks,
and I really think this fire bender
attacking them inside the temple is fire
Lord seasoned himself,
which is another change from the original series.
during the original show, Fire
Lord Susan wasn't with the soldiers
that were actually killing all the air nomads.
Like he wasn't killing all the air nomads himself.
He just stayed behind and ordered the hit
on all the different air temples.
this also gets to the next big change that
the showrunners said they made to the original show.
during the original book, one or season one,
Susan's Comet was a huge
ticking clock that they constantly reference
throughout the episodes in.
The idea was that once he came out of the ice
and had to make it to the Crescent Island
Fire Temple by the winter solstice
because of how fast Susan's comet was approaching
so that he could learn all of the things
they needed to learn from Avatar, Roku,
the actual comet itself
didn't come back and boost the powers of Ozy,
all the other fire benders on the planet
until Book three or what will be season three.
They constantly reference
the timeline of the comet on the show.
Like the comets coming.
It's getting closer.
It's getting closer in and having to learn to master
all four elements before it came
so that he could defeat fire.
Lord Ozai,
The whole idea is that in order for avatars to enter
the Avatar state at will,
they had to be able to master all four elements.
So when Aang was entering the Avatar state
during book one, it was more on instinct.
if he were to get into a fight with Ozai
during book one,
he wouldn't be able to enter the Avatar state
unless he was about to die,
it would just be his body automatically
acting to protect itself And if he still couldn't
master all four elements and enter
the Avatar state at will, by the time the comet came,
the comet itself would make ozai vastly,
vastly more powerful because of the proximity.
what the showrunner said happened though, is that
because they didn't think that they'd be able
to get season two out, the show hasn't been renewed
for season two, at least officially,
so it might be two years
before they actually get it out
in the kids on the show
playing all the characters age so quickly
that they're probably going to have to add a time jump
that wasn't in the original show.
So in order to give them a little bit
more time for him to master
all four elements and then to get through
all these different seasons for the original show,
they just removed a lot of references to the comet
that were in that original series.
Generally, I think the idea is the live action
show's going to take them like 4 to 5 years
to completely finish.
If they don't get seasons out every single year,
which it doesn't sound like they'll be able to do
so the showrunner was kind of preempting this,
saying that they're probably going to add time
jumps between book one book
two in book three to explain why
the actors look so much older
by the time book three rolls around.
whereas on the original show, only about two years goes
by between the beginning and the end of the series.
and pretty much
everybody looks the exact same with a few exceptions,
like Zuko probably looks the most different
because he's sort of wearing his hair differently.
Aang also did start
letting his hair grow out during book three,
but that was mostly just to hide the fact
that he was the Last Airbender on the planet,
that would have given him away pretty quickly
when he was trying to learn fire bending,
because at that time in history
he was the actual Last Airbender on the planet.
That's why the whole show was called Avatar,
The Last Airbender.
all the other Airbenders weren't born
till he and Katara started having children
much later in the timeline and then again
they started coming back in force
when Harmonic Convergence happened in Korra.
Much later in the timeline, when the spirit world
became connected with the physical world again,
that was viewed
as more of the true restoration of the air nomads.
So in present day after the events of Korra,
there are a ton of Airbenders again.
a lot of people
asking about some of the other major characters too.
Like where is Cabbage Man?
How come we haven't seen Cabbage Man?
Technically,
he is in the trailer when they're entering.
Imagine you can actually see his cart here
with all of his cabbages right at the entrance,
right at the gates here, I believe the person playing
Cabbage Man is just the voice actor
who did him on the original series.
I think he just came back
and he's playing him in live action now.
lot of people asking about Toff
to what's going on with Toff
because she didn't show up
until book two in the original series.
I'm not expecting you to see Toff during season one.
They might just wait till they actually start
filming season two to actually cast an actress.
maybe, maybe there's a post-credits scene or
some references to her at some point during the season.
But I don't think we'll actually see an actress
as the character until they get to season two.
Probably One of the other biggest differences
too, is they made Fire
Lord Ozai and Azula much bigger characters
during season one.
So Fire and Ozai is meant to be the main villain
of the entire series,
but it has really become a huge character until book
three For the most part, Avatar plays out a little bit
like Star Wars with Darth Vader in the Emperor
or like Lord of the Rings with Saruman in Sauron,
you start out with the mid boss,
then you work your way up to the main boss.
it sounds like there's going to be a lot more scenes
with Ozai during season one
and they also made Azula a much bigger character
so that she doesn't just show up
at the very end of the season in like a post-credits
scene the way that she did in the original book.
One she doesn't really become one of the major
antagonists until Book two in the original series.
for the actual live action series
this that they wanted to flesh out her character arc
way more
so just expect Azula to get way more screen time, way
more scenes that weren't in the original series,
most of the Azula fans out there.
I think most people are Azula
fans will actually just be happy about this.
Like, yeah, they're giving Azula more material.
I cannot wait to see her
go just completely batshit crazy during this.
my only minor complaint about the way
they've revealed the Azula character right now
is that in all the character posters they've given her,
she just has the red flames in Azula
is famous for having blue flames
because she is a fire bending prodigy.
so at some point, hopefully
like in the next couple of weeks, they'll correct that
and they'll release a new poster for her
with Blue Flame instead of just the regular flames.
we haven't actually seen her fire
bending during any of the trailer footage here,
like she's firing the bow and that's about it,
I believe during the actual series,
when she does fire bend, it will be the blue flame
for the most part,
all their bending effects actually look pretty solid.
I think that was one of the things that took them
the longest to figure out how to do that
with special effects and not make it look weird.
we'll probably get a couple more trainers
before the series drops.
So of course I'll do more videos
as we get more of that stuff.
If you have any questions or bonus videos
you want to request, just let me know in the comments.
cannot wait to do more Avatar videos.
It has been so long since we've done Avatar videos.
Click here for that other brand new Avatar
The Last Airbender Trailer with a whole bunch
more Easter Eggs and click here for that
new Invincible Season 2 Episode 5 Trailer video.
Because that series is also coming back
really soon too.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!